virtual reality is a little bit like us
like a spotlight
the experience of the mind sort of being
in this environment when it's immersed
in this sort of peaceful positive
environment it's almost like the rest of
your experiences are unable to be
noticed because it recruits so much of
the brain to focus on that spotlight
that everything outside of that
environment fall to the wayside during
that experience of virtual reality see
design I here in LA is one of a handful
of hospitals experimenting with a
surprising new treatment for people
suffering acute pain wonder if we could
start by asking how long you been here
at cedars-sinai yeah I've been here for
about four days now from chronic back
pain okay just taking some medications
and possibly an epidural very soon I'm
in the hospital because I have a total
artificial heart and last week it had a
failure I've been on the heart and
medication for pain for five years I'm
really trying to get off of it so I'm
constantly having pain of my left upper
quadrant and my right lower quadrant it
goes into my back I can't relax I have
had every test possible
there was a surgery I'd do it today
chronic pain is more than just a
physical experience but it's the
biopsychosocial experience and virtual
reality has a way of affecting people
physically emotionally and to some
degree even socially I'm excited to to
try something different something new
yeah every time they send us a new one
it's a little bit lighter so you want to
go to Iceland I'll try that you afraid
of heights
I'm not Oh perfect
virtual reality undoubtedly has an
effect on human mind
it sort of hijacks the brain it can be
used for for evil but it can also be
used for good what are you seeing like
ice formations
it makes you feel you can grab them you
know honestly in the 18 years I've been
practicing medicine I can't think of
anything that I've done that's more
effective and you can physically see
their body language change they often
will look straight ahead like they're
looking at a still image the moment that
they turn their head that's sort of the
magical moment yeah the Oz back has said
it at the very least it does no harm and
it's got the potential to cut down on
the need for drugs like morphine make
patients more relaxed and even have them
wanting to go home sooner would this be
something you might reach to before
let's say morphine I'm sure that I'll
probably try this first followed by the
the rest of the stuff right that was in
a million years I never would have
thought that they would have brought it
to a hospital to use it really felt like
I was there and this helps me relax and
when the muscles relaxed the pain goes
away VR seems to take patients out of
that pain at least for a while
but it also seems to take them out of
the confines of their hospital beds
while they have the headsets on for
those trapped by their conditions for
long periods that may be a welcome
relief and help mitigate some of the
stress of being in hospital you know
it's kind of like a jail cell really I
can get out I can go around and I can
walk and everything else but you still
end up in this floor by
we need a virtual-reality pharmacy
shelves so to speak of VR content that's
evidence-based that I can reach off the
shelf and map to my patients needs and
the more that that we have the broader
the opportunities we have to engage the
nation's with virtual reality this is
not about Silicon Valley entrepreneurism
it's about when and whether we should
interact technology with the compelling
human experience of being a patient it's
not a computing science it's not an
engineering science it's a social
science